hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A I'm Jason Bradley and it's always an
exciting time when we can open God's
word and study it out together thank you
so much for submitting your questions
I'd like to encourage you at this time
if you have a pen handy to grab that pen
grab a piece of paper be prepared to
write down some of the scriptures
because this is a fastpaced program and
sometimes that we call out script
and you're going to want to jot those
down our panelists are going to answer
your questions from the word of God but
if you haven't submitted your questions
I want you to know how you may do so so
that those can get answered in a future
program you can text your questions to
618 228
3975 again that's 618 228
3975 or you can email your questions to
Bible QA
3abn.org
to have you here it's wonderful to be
here such a privilege thank you for your
questions and giving us the opportunity
to study these from the Bible amen we
have Daniel parin sitting next to you
Daniel that's right glad to be here yes
yes good I'm looking forward to hearing
what God has given you and uh pastor
rafy we have you joining us via
Skype I'm here I'm here good to be here
good to be here thank you great to have
you here yes amen shelie before we dive
into the word of God would you pray for
us please I'd love to our loving
Heavenly Father father we come before
you with Thanksgiving in our hearts we
thank you for our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ we thank you for your Holy Spirit
and your word pour out your spirit now
on us as we answer and on all who hear
and may these answers bless each and
every one of us we love you father we
thank you for this time to study your
word in Jesus we pray amen amen amen
thank you Pastor rafy will come to you
with this first question here is it
known who the saints were that were
raised when Jesus gave up his spirit in
Matthew 27: 52- 53 in verse 53 it
mentions them going into the holy city
and appearing to many what a shock this
must have been to those who saw them
please clarify who they were and if they
are with Christ now this is from Cheryl
in
Illinois great question Cheryl in
Illinois just want to clarify Matthew 27
they were resurrected after the
resurrection of Jesus not right at the
time that he gave up the spirit if you
read those verses there'll be some
clarification there after his
resurrection so we don't really know the
specifics uh perhaps John the Baptist
was among them perhaps Simeon you know
people that were known uh in Jerusalem
at that time godly people uh fellow Jews
but we don't really know who they were
they're not identified by name in the
Bible uh they were raised with Christ
and they are now with him in heaven
that's what we're told in Ephesians
chapter 4 and very clearly there that
that he led captivity captive and of
course we see this uh confirmed in the
Book of Revelation how so well in
Revelation 4 we have a picture of the
throne room and when we compare that
picture with Isaiah chapter 6 and with
Ezekiel chapter 1 and chapter 10 and
Daniel chapter 7 all of those are Old
Testament pictures of the throne room
where we see and seraphim and Angels
where we see God's Throne high and
lifted up and where prophets like Isaiah
were taken up in Vision to see God's
Throne we notice there's one thing
missing and that is the 24 elders but in
Revelation CH 4 the 24 Elders are there
they are there for the first time in a
throne room scene in the book uh in the
Book of Revelation in in the Bible the
first time the elders are present is in
revelation after the Ascension of Jesus
Christ so we can almost assume assume
just based on that alone that these 24
Elders are those that were resurrected
after Christ's Resurrection we also see
in in Revelation uh 5: 9 and 10 that
these 24 Elders say that they were
redeemed from among nations and peoples
and tongues by the blood of the Lamb so
there we have a confirmation not only so
but we know that these 24 Elders are
wearing white robes which were promised
uh which was promised to those who
overcome in the Church of Sardis they
were wearing crowns which was promised
to those who overcome in the Church of
Smyrna and they sit on Thrones with
Christ and that was promised to those
who overcome in the Church of leosa so
we have really good evidence here that
these 24 elders and by the way in the
Bible only human beings are ever
referred to as Elders so we have really
good evidence here and we could go into
a lot more detail that even though we
don't know the specific identity of the
24 Elders we do know that they were
redeemed human beings resurrected when
Christ was resurrected went into
Jerusalem to witness for him and were
taken up with Christ when he went to
heaven and they're now in the presence
the The Throne Room presence with the
robes with the crowns with the throne
sitting on Thrones that were all
promised to those who overcome so praise
God they have been redeemed and they are
in Earnest of each one of us who put our
faith and trust in Jesus Christ for
salvation amen amen thank you Pastor
raford you know I always love when you
end up having to go to Revelation or
Daniel e either one I love that and uh
hopefully we jot down some questions to
ask the Lord when we get there that that
may not be answered in scripture um
Daniel was Luke a gentile how do we know
this is from James all right now I I
always grew up hearing that Luke was a
gentile and I wondered why and so let's
find out why the name Luke only appears
in three B texts ironically none of them
are in the Book of Luke we're going to
look at at least one of them here but
the first clue is that the name Luke is
not a Hebrew name uh it it means light
giving but it's not a Hebrew name but
that's not conclusive evidence because
there were a lot of uh Jews who took on
who had a name that they use a Greek
name that they would use to interact
with the world kind of like John Mark
you have John Hebrew name and Mark a
Greek name but let's take a look at one
of those texts where we find Luke's name
it's in the book of Colossians 4:
10-14 and Paul is giving some greetings
here near the end of the book of
Colossians and here's what he writes
arist starus my fellow prisoner GRE
prisoner greets you with Mark the cousin
of Barnabas about whom you received
instructions if he comes to you welcome
him and Jesus who is called Justice
these are my only fellow workers for the
kingdom of God who are of the
circumcision that they have proved to be
a comfort to me so stop right there
these are the only fellow workers with
me who are of the circumcision so that
would be of the Jews see there are
Jewish people notice that Luke's name
was not included in there we're about to
read it verse 12 epais who is one of you
a bonder servant of Christ greets you
always laboring fervently for you in
prayers that you may stand perfect and
complete in all the will of God for I
bear him witness that he has a great
Zeal for you and those who are in lead
DEA and those in hieropolis Luke the
Beloved Physician and Deus greet you so
here we find Luke and we actually get to
this is the spot where we learn his his
uh profession as a physician but Luke
then is not included in that list of
those of the circumcisions so we see
that Luke was not among the Jews wasn't
one of the Jews we see Luke in a couple
of other texts and I'll point out just
one more here 2 Timothy 4 verse 11 only
Luke is with me so Luke is is uh Paul
Paul writing here that Luke was one of
Paul's Companions and we know in the
book of Acts that uh it's written from a
first-person perspective of somebody
who's with him and accompanies him to
Rome and stays with him there and uh so
uh the the early Church Believers
recognize that Luke was the author of
Luke and acts but I want to end here
with this Luke was also a Jew how so go
with me to the Book of Romans chapter 2
verse 26 28 and 29 therefore if an
uncircumcised man that'd be a non Jew
keeps the righteous requirements of the
law will not his uncircumcision be
counted as circumcision then verse 28
for he is not a Jew who is one outwardly
nor is circumcision that which is
outward in the flesh but he is a Jew who
is one inwardly and circumcision is that
of the heart and so Luke here by putting
his faith in Jesus could become
spiritually one of the Jews think about
Genesis 17:4 where God promises Abraham
that he will be the father of many
nations that's actually quoted by Paul
in Romans
4:17 where he calls Abraham the father
of many nations that word there is
Gentiles so all of us can be among uh
among the the family of Abraham
receiving the promises that were
promised to him amen excellent breakdown
Daniel Shelly do we have the Holy Spirit
before or after baptism this is from
Alex from Tennessee that is an excellent
question Alex let's see if we can answer
it to your satisfaction in Acts 19
1-5 Paul comes along finds a group in
Ephesus disciples who have been
baptized and they were taught by Apollos
who didn't have all the truth at the
time Paul said did you receive the Holy
Spirit when you were baptized and they
going we never even heard of the Holy
Spirit didn't know he existed he says
into what baptism were you B baptized
and they said John's and he says this
that John's baptism is merely a baptism
of repentance to turn people's hearts
toward the Messiah who was coming after
John verse 5 says when they heard this
they were baptized in the name of the
Lord so John's baptism was a baptism a
sign of repentance it was not a sign of
new life as the Christian baptism is
so even though they believed in Christ
as the Messiah their instruction was
incomplete their understanding was
incomplete so they were rebap tized now
we find
Cornelius who was a gentile Centurian of
the Roman Armory Army and he lived in
cesaria and what happened God sent the
Apostle Peter to this godly man who was
a gentile but who had accepted the Lord
and so he sent Peter to give him the
message of the Gospel in Acts 4 uh 10
and verse
44 Peter's addressing Cornelius in the
house of Cornelius and it says while
Peter was still speaking these words the
Holy Spirit fell upon all who heard the
word wow the Holy Spirit came to them
their hearts were converted they turned
to the Lord they believed now
there were Jews that Paul had taken with
him and they Paul asks them in verse 47
can anyone forbid water that they should
not be baptized who have received the
Holy Spirit just as we have and he
commanded them to be baptized in the
name of the Lord so the house of
Cornelius was baptized with a holy
spirit first then they were baptized
with water we have to understand what
Christan Chris baptism in is
Romans 6: 3-6 are the most critical
scriptures to understand Christian
baptism Paul says do you not know that
as many as us as were baptized into
Christ Jesus were baptized into his
death therefore we were buried with him
through baptism into death this is when
we go under the water and
just as Christ was raised from the dead
by the glory of the father even so we
should also walk in the newness of life
I think of baptism as burying our past
it is symbolic of something that God has
already done in our heart what do I mean
I believe that we do receive the holy
spirit always before baptism because we
have been converted let me tell you when
you go down into the water if you
haven't been converted and you're a
sinner and you go into baptismal Waters
you're going to come up a sinner as well
baptism he says in verse uh chap Romans
6 verse5 if we've been United together
in the likeness of his death certainly
we shall also be in the likeness of his
resurrection knowing that our old man
was crucified with him that the body of
sin might be done away with that we
should no longer be slaves to sin
baptism is a public confession that we
believe in Christ Jesus it's a public
confession of what God has done in our
heart we are identifying with the Lord
Jesus he's established this as the
ordinance to for his death burial and
Resurrection amen or his burial rection
amen amen thank you Shelly pastor rafy
this is your four-minute question can
you please explain Psalm 109:
6-15 who is this talking about what
benefit does it have to be in the Bible
this is from oid in
Indiana hi over it in Indiana thank you
so much for this question it's a great
question Psalm 109 and many other Psalms
are David's way of processing anger now
we see this again and again in the
Psalms uh and it's vitally important for
us to understand because if God's people
do not learn how to process anger
responsibly they will process anger
irresponsibly so we can outline this uh
Psalm and we'll use an example in Psalm
54 and we'll go back to this Psalm we
can outline this Psalm in the uh acronym
of help h e LP help Psalm 54 is a short
Psalm it has seven verses and this is
what David would do often when he was
meeting with difficulty challenges
people that were mistreating him he
would first start out H help me Lord
save me Psalm 54:1 says oh God by thy
name and Judge Me by thy strength hear
my prayer oh God give ear to the words
of my mouth so that's the e h for help
then e explained he would explain his
situation verse three of Psalm 54 for
strangers are risen up against me and
oppressors seek after my soul they have
not set God before them seot so we have
this H help me Lord e explain the
situation and then he would go into to L
which is letting out his wrath letting
out his anger behold he says in verse
four God Is Mine helper the Lord is with
them that with them that uphold my soul
he shall reward evil unto my enemies cut
them off from thy truth and so we have
this anger this moment of of emoting
that David has letting out all of his
wrath all of his feelings to god notice
that to God and then in verse six of
Psalm 54 I will freely sacrifice unto
thee I will praise thy name oh lord for
it is good for he has delivered me out
of all my troubles verse 7 and my eye
has seen his desire upon my enemy so
Psalm 109: 6-5 15 are the angry verses
of David's prayer to God if you look
through Psalm 109 you're going to find
that verses 1 21 26 and 27 are David's
plea for help verses 2-5 22-25 are
David's explanation of what he's going
through verses 6- 20 28 and 29 are the
verses where David is processing his
anger and those are the verses you
picked up on verses 6 through 15
actually go through 20 28 and 29 where
he's angry and he's letting out all this
anger to God he's processing his anger
with God and then verses 30 and 31 are
David's praise so H help me Lord e
explaining the situation L letting out
his anger and P praising the Lord h l p
help he does this all through the psalm
Psalm 54 Psalm 59 Psalm 109 now you ask
the question who is this talking about
well I think if you read the verse
carefully the verses carefully I think
this is talking about shimi in 2 Samuel
16 7 and 8 shimi begins to Cur he's uh
of the of the lineage of the House of
Benjamin and was faithful to Saul and he
begins to curse David because David is
fleeing from Absalon one of his sons and
as he's cursing David one of David's
soldiers say basically uh he's cursing
David he's throwing stones at him the
the one of David's soldiers basically
says to him just say the word and and
and uh I'll go over there and I'll I'll
kill this dog abashi says this and the
King responds and says whatat do I have
to do with you you son of Zariah let him
curse because the Lord has said unto him
curse David who shall then um say
wherefore art thou doing that why are
you doing this and David says to abashi
and to all his servants behold my own
son who came forth from my bowels as
seeking my life how much more this
benjamite let him do it let him alone
let him curse for the Lord has bidden
him and maybe the Lord will look upon my
Affliction and the Lord will requite me
good for his cursing this day and I want
to add one more letter to h l p and that
is surprise this must have surprised
David's servants and of course it
surprises us but this is what happens
when we process our anger uh in a way
that is healthy we will surprise people
in the way we treat them when they
mistreat us very wow amen I love that
breakdown the different stages and
phases that you just outlined too
powerful thank you amen Daniel the Bible
states that the prophet Samuel had Sons
but it never mentioned that he got
married why is that all right now we can
actually ask questions like this all
over the Bible uh you go through Genesis
chapter 5 and nine Generations after
Adam all the men are mentioned no wives
are mentioned Peter had a mother-in-law
well who was Peter's wife uh Daniel
doesn't show up named in Daniel chapter
3 where was he why didn't the Bible tell
us that so I want you to look at the at
the Bible as if it's a story a big story
and in a story there is a main character
and then there are supporting characters
in The Bible Jesus is the main character
listen to what he says in John 5:39 you
search the scriptures for in them you
think you have eternal life but these
these scriptures are they which testify
of me in other words I'm the main
character now you don't get as many
details on the lives of the supporting
characters as you do for the main
character we know that so let me give
you this principle here that uh we find
in John 21 verse2 it says and there also
there are also many other things that
Jesus did here's John writing which if
they were written one by one I suppose
that even the whole world itself could
not contain the books that could be
written so John himself tells us I could
have written more but if I give you too
many details it's going to Cloud your
mind crowd out the things you need to
know so now let me give you the answer
to this question also in the Book of
John 20:3 1 John says and truly Jesus
did many other signs in the presence of
his disciples which are not written in
this book but these are written that you
might believe that Jesus is the Christ
the son of God and that by believing you
may have life in his name so God
inspired the the authors of the Bible
what to write and what not to write
because God is not interested in simply
satisfying our carnal appetite for Holy
trivia he's going to give us what we
need for
salvation you think about this in an
example in John chapter 6 where Jesus
has fed the multitudes and then uh the
people respond what sign will you
perform then that we may see it and
believe you give us another miracle and
Jesus doesn't satisfy that carnal
appetite he simp he says essentially
I've given you what you need and it is
me it is who I am so all those things
that the Bible did not include that we
wonder about we'll learn those in heaven
be patient have faith we'll know those
things so let me close here with
something that I heard somebody say many
years ago listen carefully I'll say it
slowly I'd rather know what I know and
not know what I don't know then to know
what I don't know and not know what I
know let me say that even differently
I'd rather know about salvation through
Jesus and not know about Samuel's wife
then know about Samuel's wife and not
know about salvation through Jesus so
I'm satisfied not knowing what God has
not revealed to me there's plenty in
there for me to learn and understand
already so here's my challenge for you
since Jesus is the main character of the
whole Bible as you read through it ask
him Lord help me to see you in this
Bible and help me to see what you want
me to believe and understand and to
change in my life as a result of this
text that I'm reading today wow I don't
even know what to say that was you got
me speechless over here that was
wonderful I love that and um yeah
salvation that's what it's all about
knowing Christ Shelly were any
Christians baptized before John the
Baptist like Adam Eve or Abraham this is
from Susie out of Colorado well Susie
God had Covenant people in the Old
Testament we see that Adam Eve Abel
Enoch Noah Seth shim job Abraham Isaac
Jacob Joseph they all knew about the
coming Messiah they were engaged in
Covenant with God looking forward to the
coming Messiah but there is no evidence
that they were baptized now things began
to change at the time of Moses there is
a practice a Jewish practice that
happened around the time of Moses
that a an immersion in a pool for a
purification and it's called the Mikvah
the Mikvah pools date back to the time
of Leviticus and possibly even earlier
to the time of Exodus we're not sure but
I've seen these deep pools when we were
in Israel and we went and saw where The
Kuman Community was there's deep pools
the for Fortress of Mada they had the
Deep Mikvah pool the um and we saw them
near the Temple Mount and what these
pools were for they were ritual baths
for extra
purification and it was required that
when the the priests would be go into
these it was required that you had this
dipping and coming up before you went
into the temple courts uh say during the
times of the festivals
but it was an especially constructed
bath of Living Water what's Living Water
living water is water that comes from a
spring or a river not a pond it has to
be living moving water think of us the
Living Water of the Holy Spirit should
flow through us so this was required of
convert
when they came into Judaism they had to
go down in this pool in the Mikvah fully
immerse thems then come up and they put
on clean new clean clothes so it
foreshadowed Christian baptism the
religious leaders of Jesus day when they
confronted John the Baptist listen to
this John 1:25 they asked John the
Baptist why then do you baptize if
you're not the Christ nor El Elijah nor
the prophet they weren't surprised about
the act of baptism that John was doing
they just wondered why he was doing it
amen amen see that's why I love this
program because people ask questions
that I wouldn't either even think to ask
and then you just broke that down so
beautifully thank you thank you you may
be sitting at home and you're wondering
well how can I send my questions in well
you can text your questions through
283975 again that's 618 228
3975 or you can email your questions to
Bible QA
3abn.org you can send us a direct
message uh at 3abn uncore official again
that's 3abn uncore official well the fun
continues pastor rafy we are coming to
you and uh this comes from oh James all
right when is the times of the
Gentiles are fulfilled as mentioned in
Luke chap 21: 24 in the new King James
version great question James and I just
want to mention I'm really glad Shelley
answer that last question that was
excellent I've never understood that
before so when is the time the Gentiles
fulfilled it's mentioned in Luke 21:24
Luke 21 is an uh prophetic chapter along
with Matthew 24 4 and Mark 13 Luke 21 is
talking about prophecy the time of the
Gentiles have to be understood in
correlation with the Book of Revelation
and Bible prophecy so let me read you a
verse in Revelation 11 2 and 3 but leave
out the court which is outside the
temple and do not measure it for it has
been given to the Gentiles they shall
tread the holy city underfoot 42 months
and I will give power to my two
witnesses and they will prophesy
1,260 days clothed in SA now we
understand as Adventist that these 42
months correlates with the Dark Ages
it's repeated a total of six times in
Revelation 11 Revelation 12 Revelation
13 and Daniel 7 so the time of the
Gentiles is specifically mentioned here
the time of the Gentiles will tread the
holy city underfoot for 42 months now
that's prophetic time so it's 1260 years
we see that as the Dark
Ages this time is what Luke is talking
about you might say well the time of the
Gentiles the Gentiles are going to tread
the whole city under foot well this is
symbolic language the Holy City
Jerusalem represents God's people being
persecuted during the time of this
prophetic time by the Gentiles now who
are the Gentiles well according to
Revelation the Gentiles are people who
profess to be God's people but they're
not you can read that in Revelation 2:9
Revelation 3:9 those who say they are
Jews and are not well who are they they
are of the synagogue of Satan they are
Gentiles they're not actually believers
they claim to be Believers but they're
not actually Believers so what we can
conclude here is that the time of the
Gentiles in Luke 21:24 correlates with
the 1260 years of the Dark Ages and the
persecution against God's true people by
the medieval Church who claimed to be
Jews or Israel but we're not they're the
ones who persecuted during this time
Matthew 24 doesn't talk about the time
of the Gentiles but it does identify
this Dark Ages period period as a Time
of tribulation such as never was Nor
ever will be again now this is because
unlike the time of trouble in Daniel
12:1 which is still future the Great
Tribulation of the Dark Ages saw 50 to
100 million of God's people killed or
murdered that never happened before in
Noah's time for example God's people
were saved it will never happen again
because in the time of trouble when
Michael stands up every one of God's
people is going to be delivered so the
Dark Ages tribulation such as never was
Nor ever will be is a little different
from the time of trouble which is a time
of trouble such as never was before
because the time of trouble is going to
introduce us to the seven last plagues
after the close of probation but there
are going to be no Martyrs after
probation closes God is going to keep
his people protect his people who are
written in the book praise God for that
thank you for that answer Pastor rafy
Daniel this um question here many people
argue that the new year for for the
followers of Christ should be celebrated
in March according to Exodus 12 please
explain okay God wants us to remember
him he wants us to remember everything
that he's done I think of Deuteronomy
8:1 beware that you do not forget the
Lord then in verse 18 and you shall
remember the Lord your God God wants us
to remember and he knows our carnal
Hearts he knows how easy it is for the
things of this world to drag us away
that we forget in the case of Exodus
12:3 God is specifically dealing with
remembering the Exodus remembering his
Deliverance which is an illustration of
Deliverance for from sin for all of us
and God gave Israel four specific ways
in Exodus 12: 13 to impress that upon
their minds so they would not forget it
we can call them memory hooks or
pneumonics uh the first three quickly
one is Passover an annual Feast
everything about it designed to prompt
the memory uh the second one was a
second annual ceremony called the Feast
of unleavened bread seven days no yeast
no work the way you lived your life what
you ate uh was a visible physical
tactile reminder to teach you to look
back and then look forward at what God
was going to do and then the third one
the consecration of their firstborn we
find that in Exodus 13: 11 to6 reminding
you that that God uh redeemed all the
firstborn of those who were under the
blood in the house and so then as as a
family then whenever you look at your
children that firstborn representing all
your children uh that that reminds you
that God has delivered you but then we
get to Exodus 12 1 and 2 this is
actually the beginning of that section
says now the Lord spoke to Moses and
Aaron in the land of Egypt saying this
month shall be your beginning of months
it shall be the first month of the year
to you now the Civil year the way the
world calculated time was not in that
month that was the month of abib uh the
month the the Civil calendar for Israel
begins in tisy this is the the seventh
month and so from this point on Israel
appears to have kept two calendars they
have their religious spiritual calendar
which is based not on what the world
says a Time begins it's based upon God's
action to remind me that my life begins
my time begins God inaugurates my
experience with him through his action
through his deliverance and we should do
that too sure the world has uh uh
January 1 and we ought to engage in that
and communicate with people about about
the the change that God wants to
transform in our own lives but we say
Lord I'm living by a different set of
days you're the one who who owns and
numbers and dictates the way I live my
life and so this then became the
starting point of counting the months
for all their festivals the religious
experience of looking forward to Jesus
beginning there with Passover so what
should we do well we should uh
participate in the things that allow us
to interact with the world there's
nothing wrong with interacting with the
world on January 1 but we are to
recognize that God is in charge of our
days we're not go supposed to go back
and participate in those feasts that
Jesus has already fulfilled but there's
nothing wrong with marking the passing
of time and the spiritual events that
God has ordained in the past that remind
us to look forward to what he's doing in
the future amen thank you Daniel this
next question it seems like a truly
heartfelt question this is from Musa out
of Texas how does one truly know that
they have overcome a certain sin it
seems that some sins are way easier to
avoid but how do you overcome all of
them I've been struggling with this a
little sins like don't do this don't do
that are easy but what about sins that
come from the Mind Musa what a wonderful
question and don't think you're the only
one who struggles with it the war
between good and evil the Battleground
is our mind we all occasionally have a
selfish carnal thought that doesn't
please the Lord and what we have to
remember though is we are not to dwell
on these thoughts because when you dwell
on something it becomes a stronghold
that will then become the motivation for
your action so your thoughts become
motivation for your action and Proverbs
23:7 says that as a man thinks in the
heart as in his heart so is he so
there's an old adage that says you can't
keep the birds from flying over your
head but you can keep them from building
a nest in your hair so let me give you a
few quick scriptures 1 Corinthians 1013
no temptation is overtaken you such as
is common to man ex I mean it's all
common but God is faithful who will not
allow you to be tempted AB beyond what
you were able but with the Temptation
will make the way of Escape that you may
be able to Bear it claim that scripture
second Corinthians chap 10:
3-6 Paul writes though we walk in the
flesh we do not war according to the
flesh the weapons of our Warfare are not
carnal but they are Mighty in God for
pulling down strongholds that are
building up in our mind casting down
arguments and every High thing that
exalts it self against the knowledge of
God bringing and here's the here's the
key bringing every thought into
captivity to The Obedience of Christ how
do we do that how do we war against
these satanic thoughts or even just
carnal thoughts are the false
philosophies and reasonings Ephesians
617 calls the word of God the sword of
the spirit you got to draw out that
sword you've got to have and by and by
the way this is the Rama word of God
this is the word you know and apply in
your life Hebrews 4:12 says the word of
God is living and Powerful sharper than
any two-edged sword I always say the
first Edge struck when he spoke at the
second Edge strikes when we speak it and
it will divide in our mind these
thoughts and we'll think no that's not
right this is God's way but we've got to
know the word of God in Psalm 119 the
psalmist said your word have hidden in
my heart that I may not sin against you
bottom line Philippians 48 and9 whatever
things are true Noble just pure lovely
or good report anything that's
praiseworthy meditate on those things
and then Paul goes on to say do them
meditate on them your thoughts will
become your actions meditate on the word
of God put put it into practice and
those sins are going to be easier to
overcome amen amen well said there's
victory in Christ amen Pastor rafy the
coin Peter got from the fish's mouth in
Matthew chapter 17:
23 through 27 what is the scripture
saying yeah good question Matthew 23
actually starts in verse 24 24- 27 when
they were come to capernium they that
received tribute money that is the
people who received the tribute or tax
for the temple this is talking about
Jewish people not Romans came to Peter
and said does not your master pay
tribute and he said yes and so he came
into the house Peter said hey they're
out there they want the tribute for the
temple and Jesus uh prevented him and
said wait a minute what do you think
Simon of whom do the kings of the Earth
take customer tribute of their own
children or of strangers and Peter said
well of strangers and Jesus said unto
him then are the children free
notwithstanding lest we should offend
them go to the Sea cast in a hook take
up the fish that first comes up and when
you have opened his mouth you're going
to find a piece of money and it'll be
perfect for you and for me give that to
them what's going on here well basically
the Jews are sending two men to Jesus to
try to trip him up you see Jesus knows
that as the Messiah he is not obligated
to pay the temple tax but if they can
get him to pay the temple tax then they
can say that by his own actions he has
denied his messiahship he's because
prophets were exempt from this tax as
the Messiah would be for sure so the
Jewish leaders are seeking to undermine
Christ's Ministry Peter doesn't
understand that he feels like oh we got
to pay this so that we can you know
remove any stumbling blocks and so
immediately he says yes you know how
Peter is he just talks right off and
Jesus says no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
we're not supposed to pay this they're
going to use this to undermine my
Ministry but at the same time let's not
offend them and so what he does is he
tells Peter to go down with them and go
fishing and when you go fishing you're
going to pick up a fish fish and when
you catch this fish open his mouth make
sure they're watching you open his mouth
take out the piece of money the coin
that's in there and give it to them it's
going to be perfect the perfect amount
for you and for me and so you can
imagine that Peter does this he goes
down to the to to the water he casts a
hook in he gets this fish he pulls out
the money he gives it to them and the
men head back to the religious leaders
with the very evidence they need to
destroy CH Christ claims to the Messiah
but wait a minute wait a minute they
have just
uh evidenced a miracle they're going to
need to deal with the way the tax was
paid and no one wants a story of a piece
of money found in a the mouth of a fish
that was the exact amount for Peter and
Messiah for Peter and Jesus to circulate
CA think about that so Jesus was a
master God gave him wisdom the Sevenfold
wisdom of God rested upon Him according
to Isaiah chap uh 11: 1 and 2 while he
was able to uh support his messiahship
and not fall into the trap at the same
time he was able to um you know appease
those who were seeking offense and this
way he was able to walk with a balanced
walk right through the center of all of
these different traps that were set for
him and this was one of those times wow
amen amen great story absolutely uh
Daniel this is your four-minute question
could you explain Genesis 9:3 was this
written before the meat restrictions
were given of no swine's flesh Etc I'm
not questioning the food restrictions
just wondered if there was a time when
there were none okay so let's do a quick
little timeline of food uh through a
little bit of the Old Testament we start
now in the Garden of Eden and food was
organic
homegrown natural unaltered balanced M
tasty as well and we move onone down the
next 1600 plus years all the way down to
the to Noah and the flood and there is
no change recorded in what people were
supposed to eat now the ungodly might
have broadened their appetite but God
did not make any changes so then we get
down to the time of Noah and the flood
and we look at Genesis 7: 2 and 8 and
God is telling Noah about bringing the
animals onto the ark and he makes a
clear distinction in both of those
verses between the clean and the unclean
and so Noah understood this clean and
unclean distinction and it was already
already known well before the time of
Moses when this was written down even
before Leviticus 11 even before it gets
written down the clean and unclean
distinction is clear in everybody's mind
and I got to believe that in the
heightened with the en heightened
intelligence that the people before the
flood have they understood this it
wasn't just an opposed rule they saw
this in science and they understood
precisely the difference between clean
and unclean now then we move after the
flood okay picture the the scene there
the landscape is ravaged and the power
of the earth to Pro produce food is
diminished it's not a it's not an
environment that is ready for productive
gardening and so we read Genesis chapter
9 verses 1 to4 so God blessed Noah and
his sons and said to them be fruitful
and mulp mly all right so God wants him
to grow and fill the earth and the fear
of you and the dread of you shall be on
every beast of the Earth every bird of
the air and all that move on the earth
and on all the fish of the sea they are
given into your hand here's the verse
Genesis 9:3 every moving thing that
lives shall be food for you I have given
you all things even as the green herbs
but you shall not eat with its life that
is you shall not eat the flesh with its
life that is its blood now I want you to
notice Four Points here the broadening
of the diet here was not a part of God's
original design and neither will it be a
part of his design for our diet in the
earth made new in other words God was
not editing his former diet from the
Garden of Eden as if it was faulty God
is simply permitting them to do uh
something which it was not so from the
beginning because of the hardness of
their hearts and because of of the
scarcity of food number two God God
permitted this broadening diet in part
because as I just said food was scarce
not because animal flesh had somehow
fundamentally changed its structure and
was now something recommended as a food
source but this was to preserve life
when there was nothing else ready to eat
and so we can see here that the change
of diet actually has a a correlating uh
a correlates to the the decreasing
lifespans if you read Genesis 11: 12 12
to 26 10 to 26 you'll see each
generation they get shorter and shorter
and shorter and shorter compared with
the nearly thousand years in Genesis
chapter 5 point number three God limited
their consumption of meat by saying
don't eat the meat with the blood in it
in other words eat it in a state that it
is Bland and
unappetizing uh because it was not to be
something that was desired but to be
something in case of necessity when
there was nothing else available and
finally number four uh though God
broadened the diet that they could eat
it was never wide open listen to verse
three every moving thing that lives
shall be food for you I have given you
all things even as the green herbs can
we eat every one of the green herbs out
there some of them will kill us and they
knew the same thing back then animals
could not God did not allow you to eat
anything because some of them are
destructive very very destructive to you
and they knew that and so so do we in
Leviticus 11 God doesn't change what had
been spoken to Noah it's simply put down
in writing what they already knew and
understood and so when God broadens the
diet there it's permitting them to save
life even as the green herbs which means
not wide open for everything but uh just
those things that are that God approves
for preserving the life amen amen well
said excellent breakdown I can't wait to
try the food on the earth made knew I'm
extremely excited about that I have to
you um Shelly why was Jonah angry with
God after he asked God to give him a
second chance this is from Emanuel oh
Emanuel let's take a look at the story
of Jonah you know many of God's prophets
prophesied against Gentile Nations but
Jonah is the first prophet that God sent
to a gentile Nation to preach repentance
this is interesting so Nineveh was the
Royal City of Assyria and they this was
a center of idolatrous worship it was a
bloodthirsty City the ninevites and
their cruelty were well known and they
were enemies of Israel so Jonah didn't
want to go God calls him says go talk go
go preach to these people I don't want
them to be saved I've been there before
I actually felt that way about someone
once but he tells the Lord I don't want
you to bless them in Salvation what does
he
do he hops onto a a ship he boards a
ship to head as far west in the other
direction as he can get he's trying to
get away from God a big storm comes up
the Lord arrang for that storm the the
people on board the crew they end up
casting Lots it falls to Jonah God
arranged for that you know what Jonah
was so adamant about not serving the
lord in this issue he was ready to die
instead of serve the Lord he just said
cast me overboard so when they did God
had arranged for a big fish we don't
know for sure it was a whale not sure
it's a huge fish that swallows up Jonah
and it God calms the sea but now Jonah's
three days three nights in the belly of
this fish he cries out to the Lord and
He God graciously gives Jonah a second
chance he has the big fish spit him up
right there on the seashore Jonah
probably came out with a little bit of a
bleached face from from the acids in the
fish's face but then
Jonah God commanded him once again to go
do this and Jonah goes into Nineveh he
preaches for 40 days he's and he's
saying 40 days and and Nineveh will be
overthrown he's hoping that it would
happen he didn't want the people to
repent so the ninevites believed in God
they fasted they repented the king even
put on sackcloth and oan ashes and
called for the fast and they truly
worshiped and were converted to the Lord
so what's going on in Jonah's heart oh
God I knew what you would do I knew how
merciful you were I knew what 1 Timothy
2:4 says that God desires all men to
come to the truth in second Peter 3:9
that the Lord is long suffering not
willing that any should perish but that
all should come to repentance Jonah had
received pardon from the Lord he'd been
spit out of that fish but he didn't want
that pardon to be extended to Nineveh
Jonah's values were completely warped
God brings up a a
plant that God prepared for Jonah's
shade guess what happens it comes up at
night and it
perishes the by the next night and
Jonah's matter than hops that God would
let something perish that he created God
rebuked him Jonah
411 he says should I not take pity on
Nineveh that great City in which are
more than
120,000 persons who cannot discern
between their right hand and their left
hand and much livestock Jonah needed God
to enlarge his heart amen amen thank you
Shelly Jonah I love the story of Jonah
there's so many valuable lessons that we
find there oh man Jonah it's it's
interesting because Jonah was in the
deepest part of the ship resting and
it's often times what's in the deepest
part of our vessel resting that causes
us to great problem that's good we want
to make sure that you stick with us in
just a moment we're going to take a
brief break we will be right back but we
want to share with you how you can send
your questions in for future programs
don't go anywhere we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
will bring you a fresh program answering
the Bible questions you send us using
God's holy word to shed light on those
texts that seem difficult to understand
to have your questions answered on a
future program just email them to us at
bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org for answers from God's
word wow our time is rapidly escaping
but I want to open the floor for any
final thoughts you may have Pastor raffy
will'll start with you just going back
to David's experience you know Psalm 109
and many other Psalms we see a lot of
anger in David and yet at the same time
we see a lot of compassion and you you
just sometimes have to wonder why did
David get so angry well he got so angry
so that he could be so compassionate
it's his anger toward God and
manifesting that anger responsibly that
allowed him to be so compassionate
toward people like Saul and like shimi
so learn how to process that anger with
God so that he can pour His grace in get
that anger out his grace into you so
that you can be compassionate and
merciful toward those who may irritate
you or those you may have friction with
amen amen Daniel yes I told you that
Luke who was a gentile was also a Jew
and that reminds me of that old
children's song that maybe irritate some
people Father Abraham had many sons many
sons had Father Abraham I'm one of them
and so are you so let's all praise the
Lord a deeply theological song right
there and it is a blessing so why do you
move with that song Because Abraham was
a nomad and he was always on the move
and we're going to heaven amen
Shelly I just want to encourage you to
remember each day to pray for the Holy
Spirit get into the word of God ask the
spirit to give you understanding claim
God's promises over your life speak them
into the lives of your children and the
the your loved ones God wants to save
you from every sin and guess what he's
going to complete the good work he began
in you amen amen thank you so much thank
you Shelly thank you Daniel thank you
Pastor rafy for the Insight that you've
been providing from the word of God we
want to thank you for sending in your
questions encourage you to stay in God's
word he wants you to understand it until
next time may God richly bless
[Music]
you